Casey starts off this hour in Kalamazoo
Michigan
hi Casey how are you I'm great hurry Oh
better than I deserve what's up I have a
really weird question for you
his family has been asking for our
financial information they want to know
what our utilities are how much we're
spending on everything and who is paying
what so I am from my family where you
don't share those things outside of your
immediate household so my question is
should we be giving them this
information or should we be holding the
barrier and like the wall that we are
saying that this is our information and
you know it's not really any of their
concern we're not in any kind of
financial need no okay and so you're
married we're not married I told them he
could not propose until I finished grad
school and I finished in about six weeks
which is a kind of another thing and
whether or not that answer changes once
we are married yeah
well it does because then it's a
different situation the because there's
not a we now and your roommates mother
is going over the line yes that's
different than your husband's mother is
going over the line for me it is and i
think and i think relationally it is
either way that she's going over the
line what is their motivation and being
sad emblem nosy honest sister his sister
why does his sister want to know his
stuff she honestly sees or whatever even
does not care for me and that's been
well known we go through points where
were fine and then other times she
doesn't but we are taking a trip as a
family to Disney this fall and his
sister spent $12,000 and I said that we
would only go if we could do it our way
and we
only spending about fifteen hundred
dollars instead of twelve thousand so
she's really upset right now that I'm
refusing to do everything that she
wanted to do and taking on extra debt
because I was only willing to go if I
kept time to save up some money and our
1,500 covers our whole little unit 33
and 34 oldest sister 39 well here's the
problem there's more going on here this
is not about money this is about your
roommates future fiance maybe future
husbands sisters relationship with you
that's what this whole thing is about
and and let me just tell you who solves
that it's not you this is just an old
man talking I'm not a family therapist
okay this is not me this because it's
not a money thing but you trying to
solve this with her is going nowhere
agreed I do agree yeah him sitting down
with her and going hey sis he did and
his whole families are not speaking to
either of us now we just disclosed all
this information if it would fix it or
boundaries and you say no I'm going to
have a boundary and then they say oh the
only way we're going to have a
relationship with you is if we can tell
you what to do in your life we're going
to violate boundaries that is not a
relationship that's a controlling
manipulative bunch of jerks I think
there's more going on here though that's
outside of my realm of expertise so I
don't know exactly how to address this
but no I know caving to people who
demand that they can violate your
boundaries is not the way you solve a
relational issue okay but I don't think
this has anything to do with Disney
and I don't think this has anything to
do with your light bill I think it has
to do with y'all living together and his
family doesn't like that and they don't
like you shacking up with their son and
it's talked about all the time and they
don't like your stance on anything and
that's what's going on and it's being
reflected in these other things that are
symptomatic so you've got a much bigger
problem than that and so you know I
think you sit down with a marriage
counselor and get some pre-engagement
pre-marriage counseling because you have
a real problem in one of the four areas
that causes marriages to end and that's
in-laws it is one of the four areas that
money fights in-law fights fights over
kids and fights over religion and when
you are unequal on any of those four
things you cannot come up with a solid
way to handle this on any of those four
things then your your marriage is going
to struggle your relationship is not
going to last so you need to see a good
marriage counselor to help you with that
and so you know you asked me and I I
don't think you can solve this by giving
them the information that's absurd it's
absurd they asked for in the first place
it's absurd they're angry because they
don't want you to they want you to spend
and do everything that you can't afford
to do that's not an act of love that's
an act of control and manipulation by
them but none of those are the problem
they're all symptoms of a bigger problem
that's a relational breakdown between
you and his family and that's what
you're going to have to get into that
I'm not qualified to deal with nor do I
care to